everybody it's gary vay-ner-chuk apis
owed 308 of the askgaryvee show and i'm
super excited about our guests just
knowing this audience and some of the
prior episodes when this inquiry came in
i kind of jumped on and said yes let's
do it right away right away in my world
i don't know if that was a couple months
ago but i've been excited about having
eivin here as a matter of fact just to
show you how much nobody know we had a
crazy big business pitch at vaynermedia
and and I got a I got a text from my
admins Thursday saying hey we need to
move the Ivan askgaryvee show for you to
make this pitch and I never use my
content to trump being the operator of
my business like never consistently
cancel things I said no no I want to
keep it because I was scared of when
would I be able to reschedule it so I'm
excited for this episode I hope you are
as well Facebook YouTube are we on
Instagram as well right here Instagram
what's up we are taking phone numbers
from YouTube and Facebook so if you're
on YouTube live and Facebook live put in
your phone number and Andy will be
taking that we're not doing the email
the question thing and do you want to do
that you like the phone number thing
okay put your phone numbers on YouTube
and Facebook and without further ado
Ivan why don't you tell the vaynernation
a little bit about who you are and a
little bit of an origin story we got
into it right before we went on maybe
where you were born what kind of kid you
are what you got into how your career
started all the way up to the fact that
you wrote this book and maybe some of
the other stuff will bounce on so a
context chapter to start off the show
okay well Gary thank you for having us -
happy I appreciate it so let's see if I
can frame this very quickly got time so
I'm the retired CEO of Verizon yes I
spent my whole career in the phone
business yes I was a CEO for 16 years
retired in 2011 what a run and when I
retired a lot of people said to me you
know the industry and the company went
through such an extraordinary
transformation over the last 20 or 30
years why wouldn't you think about
writing some sort of a history of the
journey of the company
it took me about four years to figure
out I wanted to do that but what really
helped was I talked to a lot of my
colleagues and we identified 50
different people that we interviewed and
we kind of told the story through the
eyes of 50 people and I apologize for
jumping in but everybody's laughing
right now cuz I love to jump in but I'm
gonna try to be a little more thoughtful
I just think there's a lot of things
that are going on that I try to bring
out to an audience did you take that
approach because the reason even took
you four years to do it was you thought
of writing a book as too self-serving
and then thus the format of using other
people's voices felt more comfortable to
you as a facilitator that's a that's an
interesting question um I was more
concerned that I would not put my finger
on the right issues good for you I did
not think I could remember all the right
points that's very so I would remember
what I wanted to remember of course so
which when you write a book some people
will think it's self-serving no matter
what you say of course but having 50
people yeah like that tell the story now
of course I was able to direct it of
course of course and then we went to an
outside consultant Rahm Charan who
helped us frame it and so we now have a
story that's through the eyes and the
the experiences of 50 different people
and the other thing we did is we decided
to take all the proceeds from the book
and donate it back into the Verizon
Foundation to give it to people who who
have been involved with natural
catastrophes like 9/11 or hurricanes in
that nature so I kind of feel like the
book is a neutral ya place I have my
thumbprint on it of course but there's
plenty of stories of other people how do
you as an individual I don't know this
I'm asking for myself as much for the
audience are are you putting out content
in general as a human do you write op
dens do you sometimes post on LinkedIn
do you have a do you have a you know
I've it's really interesting I'm a CEO
and a personality that is growing up in
the era of sharing along the way you're
part of a generation where you know it
could have gone to very different ways
but have you thought of do you feel like
lessons I mean sick now Verizon was
public the whole time you know 16 years
is an active CEO of a publicly-traded
company comes with a lot of experiences
and a lot of knowledge this is about the
story of horizon do you at this point in
your career ever feel compelled to
randomly write something on LinkedIn or
go do a podcast to just talk about what
it is to be a leader of people or
navigate through turmoil does that come
natural to you well the short answer to
your question was when I retired I
decided I would not cast any shadow on
your over our company or the industry so
I have written other than the book I've
done that no interviews no conferences
nothing but I have chosen to have
relationships with 20 30 40 50 people
that I have kept in touch with so any
personal experiences of advice I can
give them I do private I totally
understand and I think that's a classic
approach of what is a very
well-respected blueprint of somebody
who's such a face of an organization and
I'm curious what then what what is gonna
continue to manifest because I do think
to your point I think there's a lot of
ways to talk about certain things that
are more generic without casting a
shadow on the prior company or the
individual that takes over that hot seat
I'm just fascinated by it nonetheless
let's keep like interesting leaves over
here for in my personal experience yes
before I wrote we wrote this book yes I
must have read a hundred biographies of
different CEOs yes and what I concluded
was no matter how well they try to hide
it somebody had an extra grind or a
story to tell I didn't feel I had any
unfinished business when I retired I was
ready to retire the company was ready to
see me go and I was very comfortable
with it and I was and I was ready to get
on to the next chapter of my life and so
I did didn't feel that I needed to keep
a finger in the industry well now you're
starting this is gonna be a fun day so
this gets me into a very interesting
thing I have been asking myself why
after from 20 so I grew up in the wine
business
I had this why
I did this wine show on the Internet and
then when I started building this
company
I wasn't producing content there is this
huge gap of me on the Internet
where I'm making content every day from
2006 to 2011 and then for four years
there's very little content of me and
then in 2015 I picked it back up
14:15 and recently I've come to realize
that I think positivity needs to be
louder it's very interesting what you
just said it's a very astute observation
I think you're right and what's
interesting in what's manifesting with
me currently this is actively happening
with me is I almost feel an enormous
sense of responsibility that as somebody
who's positive and optimistic yet
practical and not delusional or entitled
I want to put out content because the
people that are putting out the most
content under the Internet
are the disenfranchised that axes to
grind the negativity and I'm fascinated
by what you had to just say because I
believe that is the approach that many
take and I'm starting to wonder if you
know I think it's a pleasant thing to
read a book from an executive who had an
incredible 16 year run who has no agenda
who's just telling stories
self-deprecating pounds in little chests
whatever maybe and I wonder and one
thing that I've been telling my audience
is like look if you're happy I think
there needs to be some level of
consciousness right now maybe sharing
that because the only negativity is very
loud and positivity positivity tends to
be a little bit more passive and I'm
fascinated by that and that was another
version of sure please so two responses
to it usually so the first thing is
almost any CEO wants to leave the
businesses in better shape than they
found it no question and and the one
measure of making sure that that works
is the institution you left controls its
own destiny and continues to do all the
things it needs to do to be sustainable
so if you have somebody who is
constantly looking back to draw the past
to the future that's not very helpful I
respect that
so people have to continually reinvent
the future going forward you know just
to show that I am human and when I left
what I learned really quickly is the
projects I got involved with there was a
tremendous curiosity of transferring my
skills having worked in the phone
business for 46 years and transfer them
to other things and so while everything
I've done since I retired is neither as
important or as big as I did when I
worked at Verizon almost everything I do
is very important to the people I work
with no question so I serve on the board
of a hospital I serve on the board of
the genome Center here in New York I'm
working with three or four startup
companies I do some consulting with
investment banking firm and all those
activities yep
draw upon my experience no question
there's a lot of fun you have a lot of
fun doing that stuff so let's go way
back
so you're a kid growing up where well
I'm a Bronx ID I grew up in the Bronx
okay well it's very interesting
oh man of your generation from the Bronx
not being a total die-hard Yankee fans
gonna have a good story so I'm excited
right now so I was a Yankee fan okay and
I like to use okay however keep going in
high school we played baseball again
same Crapo and Kranepool became a man
and then the Yankees fired yogi yes they
did
and once they fire yogi I was no longer
Yankee so you were such a big Yankee fan
well how could you not be a Yankee fan
when you're eating a lot no I apologize
I said the wrong thing you were such a
big Yogi fan that the firing of yogi I
hated the way the Yankees treated yogi
when they fired him I get it and then I
needed an excuse to root for the met
Jenny right so I've been a met fan ever
since I love it and I am today one of
the small minority owners of the Mets
okay so that's even believable know
what's really funny about this this is
something that made me feel don't know I
grew up a big Yankee fan in Jersey which
she had split I was a Jets Yankee guy so
it was like you know you had different
kind of allegiances but the Yankees won
in 96 and that was it when the Rangers
won in 94 oh and Yankees won in 96
I stopped rooting for my favorite team
like literally just winning a
championship has been the finishing
point to the journey and I'm actually
raising my son a Mets fan because his
cousins are
pants and so we're gonna go through a
very similar thing because I'm gonna get
sucked in it's like both teams I'm a big
fan yeah I get it
and when the Yankees play the Mets a
route for the Mets I understand
absolutely
what about football Giants jets Jets
very good all right my complete energy
has changed okay um so go ahead please
actually if you think about it growing
up in New York in the 60s
I wasn't corporate I get it so I like
the Jets like the match you know I get
it what year did you switch the Mets
well first year sit well sit right away
the Yankees fired yogi in 64 okay right
and the Mets were in 62 so I started
right there I'm sick come on the Mets
made yogi manager you were pom I loved
it
you must love that and it's a kid I was
a really nice fan how old were you in 69
when the Jets and Mets won I was born in
46 oh so you were perfect
you were like an O beautiful age right
so you really got it oh yeah no my
generation New York sports Nix Nix the
Dodgers and Giants were in New York and
the 50s so there was great New York was
full of great sports all right so you
grow up in the Bronx what kind of kid
are you entrepreneur student like what
kind of dude are you dopey kid okay you
know I
well the gag through school you know
challenge you you know I wouldn't say
that I think that schools I went to were
good schools they challenged you but was
it dopey kid I didn't pay attention and
I ended up going to Lehman College at
the time was Hunter College what for one
year it's in the book they threw me out
after a year I didn't I didn't have good
grades and I got a job working for the
phone company luckily as a well
actually this is my high school report
card no matter how dopey you are you're
gonna have to really really work
challenging that beauty I would
challenge you with my I need do you have
it I probably have it someplace I need
to see that evidence good but so anyway
I went to college
yep I got a job during the day working a
freight elevator in Manhattan then I got
drafted because I was 1a yeah and lo and
behold I work for the phone company for
one month when I got drafted and I
served in the service for 24 months and
thinking about the phone company is they
used to write me letters and send me
information they treated me like I still
belong to them even though I only worked
for them for a month Wow and so a
company that was New York telephone
telephone and then when I came out of
the army I went back to work for the
telephone company and went back to night
school and finished night school 12
years later and phone company was always
a great place for me because they took
care of me and they helped me grow up so
I went from dopey kid - not as dopey -
an army veteran you learn a lot of stuff
in the army and then then you work in a
big institution you learn a little
discipline and then I met my wife when I
got out of the service and she gave me
more disappointment and then you build a
career and then you know one thing leads
to the other and let's spend a few
minutes on one thing leads to the other
New York phone company until when sorry
you're in a New York phone company until
when oh no I was if you look at it the
way you asked the question I started in
the in the New York telephone company in
66 and was part of a system all the way
till I retired in 2011 that's what I'm
looking for the consolidation the
breaking out the mergers the M&A is how
did it all go down well I I started in
New York telephone company I went to
AT&T I worked a little bit of Bell
Laboratories
when the 18t was broken up back in the
early 80s I went with the New York
regional company
and then they moved me to Washington and
I lived in Washington and then we
started consolidating the companies and
then we bought cellular companies and we
started reconstructing the industry and
you know I was one of the people that
over the years too had a lot of
experience in working at different parts
of the system so probably my
contribution to Verizon probably was to
help reconstruct the industry after the
the government broke it up we spent the
next 25 years recreating a different
industry but one that had scale and
scope and focused on Wireless and
focused on broadband all the things you
guys liked can we can we can we focus a
little bit on the break up yeah sure
how long was that in the air before it
actually went down how long was it in
the public consciousness or behind the
scenes or in the press with that hey
this thing is actually good question so
it's a good question because it has
relevance to what's going on today with
it so I'm asking right history by the
way in that crappy report card the only
good grades I had or history besides Jim
I was a gym class hero for ace there any
only A's on my report card but I asked
that question and you're very astute
it's it's self-serving I do think
history is an enormous indicator to the
future and I I haven't had the
opportunity to really dig in and so I'm
taking my at-bat right now I'm curious
so so in a nutshell if you looked at the
old bill system yes old 18 - yes 70s
there were two complaints that just
wouldn't go away the first is they were
stifling new entrants from coming into
the market so they were a big monopoly
and the matter how many companies wanted
to get into the phone business even
though the technology was there for it
to happen
it never really blossomed and the second
thing is the government itself kind of
gave up and said they're too big to
regulate we can't figure it out and so
to your question that was going on for
probably five to ten years before that
but it never got traction but then it
started to get traction why from your
one man's point of view
well okay a the government was getting
more serious about it and they were they
were suing the company all the time and
they were getting extremely aggressive
about trying to correct those things
that they thought were a problem which
is barriers to entry and they couldn't
regulate it but the other thing that
happened is the company itself lost the
ability to grow
so once ATT itself said look I can't
deal with all this government
interference and regulation and I'm
having trouble growing myself myself
that's when they got together and they
agreed on a consent decree that broke up
the company so if you look at today some
of the tech companies not all of them
but some of them they look too big to
regulate they've become global they have
no allegiance nor grounding in any
country they operate to a different set
of standards and people getting
frustrated
that simple things that should be
governor Oran now they haven't run into
the problem of no growth that's right so
but they will at some point growth will
slow and there will be forces in which
governments around the world and the
companies will come to the conclusions
is another paradigm that's necessary
here I understand so these things run in
cycles no I tend to be more market-based
so I'm not looking for government
mandated solutions I think the tech
companies deserve a lot of credit for
what they've built but they have run
into a situation which not all of them
are serving customers the way they
should understand and so therefore I
think these things will come to a head
over the course of next four or five
years it's interesting to me in the
current state of the tech companies
versus the AT&T parallel is there
weren't alternatives to use a different
phone provider like like you know like
it was the alternatives were super
difficult like your ability to not use
Facebook or Google is quite high like my
ability to use Yahoo or Bing as a search
engine or not be on Facebook or
Instagram is extraordinarily high
I think one of the most fascinating
things that are happening right now in
the current conversation of tech
companies is the shocking inability for
Americans to take any level of
accountability on themselves well so
this is interesting so if you go to
history which say people used to make
that argument about coca-cola they're
the cause of obesity what people would
make that case against the phone company
by saying we're teaching kids to sit on
the phone say that one more time because
so I was really excited what you just I
want to get back to coke I'm not
advocating no I know you're not but
there's a business permit oh I I love
what you just said the amount of parents
right now that are too young to remember
an era when the phone company was blamed
for kids being on the phone all day I
mean they're just doing the same thing
like I watch parents yep complain about
the iPad and I'm like take the iPad away
from your kid they're as if the iPad as
if Apple controls them no but but as a
business yeah I'm listening we had to be
sensitive to of course these kinds of
arguments of course we had to balance
making money against do a right thing
horse butt but you have to pay attention
to these things over the course of your
history because the public will hold you
account for s--
but where's the public's accountability
I mean to me that is the great
fascinating thing about this you know
maybe I'm hyper sensitive to this
because I was born in the Soviet Union
and but you know I listen I commend
Apple debating should they make apps
that stop you from screen time it's all
very wonderful coca-cola has Diet Coke
there is ZERO sugar coca-cola where
where does it stop and sorry Mike
Bloomberg in this great city tried to
limit how big a soda is and got the
reaction in the other way yeah I I think
what's fascinating is watching people
I'm fascinated by 70 or 80 years of
prosperity listen your man from a
different generation a lot of like the
people that I'm referring to right now
who you know I believe that we've had so
much prosperity in this country that you
know we've gotten quite sigh I just I'm
just fascinated by lack of
accountability I really am well so this
is a political discussion so I'm not
gonna get and honestly you'll appreciate
this
I am NOT interested in the play I don't
business as a business and to me it's a
business discussion yeah so I agree with
almost everything you said but there is
an issue that we have looked at the last
thirty years and we have created more
inequality than we intended to create so
we have overdosed on technology we've
overdosed on yeah but let's placing
people with technology you're preaching
but we have to figure that out I'm with
you and to your point not to make this a
political conversation here's the
problem our overdosing on technology
hasn't even begun there's a naivete like
right I mean like tech not this is the
right this second is the least amount of
Technology involvement in perpetuity
correct so we need to accept that
because ideology super fun but making
your kids spend an hour less on the iPad
is not gonna solve a lot of these human
truths right so if we look at I'll use
it our business and and I apologize real
quick to cutting you up I think to segue
a little bit because I think it's gonna
bring value to the audience what I love
about the conversation we're having is
these are the macro macro trends that a
CEO where she and he has to be thinking
about on an everyday basis of the micro
like these things were talking about in
the world is how you thought about the
four walls the virtual four walls of
horizon for 16 years everything is
important at all time the amount of
things that happen here the point you
were making about coca-cola and I wasn't
picking on them but no you weren't you
were actually doing exactly right I
spend every day about perception becomes
reality becomes what you have to deal
with yeah so if I can bring this fast
forward please
so one of the things our industry always
had a lot of pride in so when we move
from first generation Wireless to third
now to fifth generation where I was 5g
what we hope will happen
is that industries that have been
untouched by technology will be
disrupted and transformed well
especially 5g I don't know so let's take
an example people do not understand the
technology jumped at this so let me use
my favorite example banking has been
changed right retail is being changed if
you go into a classroom it looks the
same as it did 40 years ago
and so when I look at education where is
the technological disruption that should
have occurred in that over the last 30
or 40 years so we need we need to see
that happen healthcare is another place
the environments a third so to me the
business community has lots to give but
there's an uneven focus around where
technology gets deployed and some of
that is inertia of some of that is
government some of that is entrenched
you know interests but the fact is we
need to take the technological
revolution and apply it aggressively
across industry so we need you know
Amazon did what it did
we need an Amazon of Education we need
an Amazon of environment to really apply
the technology and that would create
jobs and we create value and it would
start to slant what we're now looking at
is all this inequality of jobs and
educational skills I understand let's
take this in a different turn what about
in your career who were your biggest
mentors and what were some of the best
pieces advice you got from them so early
in my career I was probably uncoachable
you thought you everything because you
know I'm a city kid you figure you could
figure everything out yourself right but
what I think the way I would answer the
question no I could see that yeah I can
see that well what what I did though is
I used to copy the people who did things
I liked and so somebody I used to like
the way they dressed or somebody else in
a meeting would handle bad news very
well or somebody would have a positive
attitude and so I used to use my mentors
with those people who had attributes
that I thought were pretty cool well you
know I actually analyzed that as a
street kid yeah you're using your
environment to make adjustments that's
true and I learned as I move up in the
company people watched everything I did
hundred percent and so to me imitation
is the best form of teaching that you
can give people if you do the right
thing or if you try to do the right
thing and it's an incredible sense of
responsibility once you make that
realization right so to answer your
question my mentors were the people who
handle controversy well who had a good
attitude who are always prepared how
much do you think positivity matters I
mean that practical positivity when I
say something like that how does that
register in your mind so remember now
I'm an East Coast kid yes
so when I hear that term I want to make
sure I ferret out the fluff go ahead so
I'd like people with a positive attitude
but I like people who are practical
street smart and get things done yep not
people who like to yak at 20,000 feet
you're interrogating positivity that's a
word you know like that's how you notice
how I framed it up right I think
positivity is imperative but if it lacks
practicality it's an ideology right so
it's vulnerable ya know so there was one
person who once gave me some advice
that's close to this point Gary and that
is we were in a meeting and a very
contentious subject and as typical in a
meeting on the East Coast when people
get upset with each other they attack
each other personally yes and so my boss
who was from Michigan just on the way
back to the to our office he took me
aside and he said Ivan why do people
around here attack each other and not
the problem
and he was sending me a message don't do
that I never forgot and I am 40 years
later and I've never forgotten it and I
sit in a room and I could tell the
people who get frustrated with the facts
or the issue or can't articulate their
point of view and the first thing to do
is attack somebody instead of attacking
the problem and it's just something so
that's an example I'm a buyer of that I
activity but I always say that I'm
unemotional and what I'm really saying
is what you just said which is the
biggest thing I preach to my direct
reports is if you're not capable of
being the bigger person in every
situation then you're vulnerable with me
because to your michigan boss's point
it's just if there's no value in that
behavior and once it was but you know I
love them you have such a good rapport
when you can do it and there it's almost
like a it's almost like you're competing
on the basketball court but it's but to
your point it's so that's cool I love
that that's a great story
so nice to bring up anything you want of
course that could bring us back to the
book so there are lots of chapters in
there but it's a couple of favorite
chapters and one of them is the story of
how our company was able to deliver
after 9/11 let's talk about it so very
quickly
9/11 occurred all right we we were the
one of the first people that will call
by the Department of Homeland Security
because they said you guys must know
what's going on what's going on and we
said we don't know what's going on we
saw the second plane hit the tower
within ten minutes when you say you saw
we were sitting in our office at the
42nd Street building looking down we saw
the first tower on flames and we saw the
plane hit the second building you
physically saw from your office window
about thirty of us listening or chief
engineer said right there on that second
he said they don't put that fire out
that building isn't going to collapse
and you guys were like what the hell are
you talking about and we told we told
other people that now we didn't know if
that was right but he was right and he
said and we said to him Larry why is
that right he said because all the steel
is gonna melt in the center of the
building is going to collapse Wow okay
so our job then because all of Wall
Street was out yeah you know all the
lower Manhattan was out and what
happened after that was the next morning
still flames still trying to look up
survivors
the calls were coming in from all over
the country about once the stock
exchange could be up and running and
every single one of the trading partners
in Wall Street I said you know will be
up Thursday we knew that wasn't true
why did you know that because they
couldn't get their people into the
buildings sorry rightfully they didn't
have alternative locations so I remember
dick Grasso was who was the chairman of
these stock units at the time he called
the meeting everybody in the city and he
brought our people and and he said so
what are we gonna do okay and and our
guys just sat there and said there's no
way that you're going to be able to
sorry get the stock your change up and
running because people won't have
facilities and besides they weren't even
letting people into ground zero at the
time right and of course anybody who
wanted to set up facilities in New
Jersey or someplace else
neither time to do it so what was
interesting is our people basically said
we could do the following
but here's all the things you will have
to do and it was very interesting how
Grasso just gravitated to our chief guy
Larry babby oh and said so what do you
need to do and so we talked about what
everybody needed to do and what the
story here was great because we were
running cables out of buildings we were
doing all sorts of things that we needed
to do but we were also helping other
people do their jobs so this is the
lesson on 9/11 for us accountability
there is no such thing as accountability
if you do your job and the next guy
can't do his accountability means we all
win together
and so we ended up committing to getting
the stock exchange up and running the
following Monday and in the process of
doing that we developed relationships
with the top 60 or 70 trading partners
development Sachs and Merrill Lynch's
all those companies to help them make
sure they can open their facilities that
enough circuits to get things done they
have the generators and the power and
everything else that needed to occur to
get the country up and running and was
one of the greatest experiences of our
careers because it's a big deal it was a
big deal and
and but it taught our company back in
2001 what real accountability is and
real accountability is not just doing
your job but it's you and your job and
helping the people you work with do
their jobs yeah I understand I mean for
you know I have such a large audience of
20 30 40 year-old entrepreneurs or
number twos and threes and smaller
companies quite a bit because of the
nature of my business
senior executives in Fortune 500's what
are some of the you know just back to
the context of this conversation what
are what are some of the things when
back to those 20 or 30 people that you
spend time with startups boards
I'm sure family and friends what are
what are some of the tried us and truest
things that come to mind that brings out
what does some of the advice are or
thoughts that you've seen bring actual
value to others in their careers or
ambitions that you feel are like I don't
want to calm your bill of rights or
Commandments but yes that kind of stuff
what are some of the truest things that
you believe in as an operator as an
executive probably the thing that comes
to mind first carries is curiosity and
the willingness to ask questions having
the humility to know that you don't know
everything well to help people think
through things yeah I mean do you think
it's hard when you get to such a senior
level as you sat on to show that you
know was it hard for you to develop the
ability to manifest curiosity into what
is humility of a leader or was that
something that came natural to you no
you know I think in my case yeah I
always came with the attitude that I
came from the Bronx so I don't think it
never dawned on me that I had the right
to act like I graduate at MIT or
understand Tintin do that right so I was
worried about making a mistake that's
right so in my case I think asking a lot
of questions being prepared taking the
next step you brought up bringing
prepared a couple times not something I
think a lot about you know I I think I
stay in my lane and so thus by macro
prepared you've brought it up three
times now how talk talk to me about that
for five seconds well what I don't think
I've ever seen a presentation brought to
me that there weren't three good
questions that you couldn't ask not to
catch people but just to dig deeper
understand the secondary and the
tertiary effects of things so so I think
it's really important to be prepared and
I'll just give you one anecdote that's
in the book so it probably helped me
make my career even though it was a
freak thing I'm excited so it was it was
in 1981 okay
and somehow I was on some sort of a task
force and I was supposed to make a
presentation to all of the high-level
people at AT&T including Charlie Brown
Charlie Brown was just chairman and CEO
of the company and I was sort of a
mid-level person okay good
and Charlie Brown was a legendary guy
yeah big time so he he shows up have you
interacted with Charlie at that point
never miss are you scared crapless where
you feel prepared I was prepared okay
and I'll tell you why I was prepared I
can't wait so no there's a bunch like
there had to be 50 people in the room
only vice president yeah and the meeting
was eight o'clock in the morning I got
there at 6:30 to make sure everything
worked and what was the technology of
the day at 81 of working it was overhead
graphs and so he walks in one minute
8:00 and he sits down no chitchat
he says proceed dead silence you know
and everybody sitting there with their
arms folded you know nobody's smiling
everything else so that's a warmest room
of all time ya know it was okay so I
started the presentation and he goes I
know that okay
put up the second charge she goes I know
that third charge she goes I know that
and I said no you don't really yeah and
now I didn't mean it as to be just came
natural right I just yeah I know you
don't know this and he dead silence in
the room he looks at me and he goes okay
proceed so he showed me something right
he didn't get upset he just tested it
and then I talked it through now the
gist of the whole presentation was even
though AT&T signed this consent
agree with the government and they were
gonna break up the system my point to
them was the government wasn't going to
cooperate with making this happen easily
so we were going to have to do some
things on our own and I remember his
lawyers and all his vice presidents
would go nuts and he just sat there he
just sat there and at the end of the
presentation he goes thank you very much
he got up and left okay that's what he
did
and of course everybody came up to me
and said you're screwed like you might
as well quit now and I remembered
nothing happened for about a week and
then I got a call from my vice president
who was a very big big person he says
coming to the office and he brought in
all the naysayers and he said now before
everybody starts screaming he goes and I
had a beard at the time for beard okay
full beard nobody had a beard at AT&T
and Walter Kelley was his name and he
said to everybody in the room he said
you know we have four sons and they all
have facial hair and this was in 1980
right and he goes we can't get them to
shave he goes what is it with you young
people you were 45 though Yeah right no
I wasn't almost because you were born in
46 you said 66 Oh 60 right right Oh 66
so you're 44 45 actually right this is
81 is anyone yeah let's do the math
right yeah 86 I was I was 40 right oh
I'm sorry you're right go ahead yeah you
got the bathroom I got a rocket right go
ahead I wouldn't want my share whole no
my man is off
I apologize go anyway he said he said
what is with the young people and and we
just left and then he said to everybody
in the room listen to the young man
that's just what he said now this was
like a high level person at 18 - you
would never think he would have that
kind of flexibility and humility yeah
but he did so it's a lessening player
lesson I never forgot I believe in it
the mote like nothing nothing makes me
happier than being wrong but I always
think I'm right but Gary if I wasn't
pleased and didn't have the
self-confidence you would have never
said it I wouldn't I totally get a
brother I would have just moved
man recombinant honestly the elec as
somebody who's always thinks there's a
second game in the room this is
basically how I live my life the amount
I know about executives that work for me
clients co-founders fancy people in the
world that people think are brilliant
the amount of things I know by asking a
singular question in a meeting the
amount of times I've made up something
to see if that person just agrees to
appease this it's like it's the most
important you have to get it when you
are sitting in a world where you walk in
one minute before a meeting and you've
got to like navigate that much and time
is your biggest enemy you have to create
all these secondary skill sets to be
able to understand the situation at hand
I have an incredible read on humans
based on moments like that
so coming back to Verizon untethered so
we believed as a culture we were as
curious as any culture could ever be so
the head of my wireless company or the
head of some of the unit's when they
knew I was travelling around the country
for whatever reason they would give me a
list of stores to go into and say go
make a field visit I used to do that and
we always to do that and we just go did
the stores know you were coming no
because one of things I hated growing up
in the liquor business is my dad had a
big liquor store and when the Smirnoff
star the absolute or the Budweiser big
dogs would come we would stage the store
and I remember when I finally was 16 and
had some level of a voice which I really
didn't even at 16 but I've been working
in the store for a couple years at that
point I said dad we're not doing that
person a service and he looked at me
like I was crazy and I go I remember
when I took over operations at 22
I never stage the store and the
distributor would be pissed the regional
manager the holding companies would be
pissed and the CEO eight out of ten
times was thrilled it was the only truth
they got but we don't know but he's
drinking your vodka sucks there's an
anecdote there's an anecdote in here
that my successor Lowell McAdam used to
also make field visits he'd go into a
store if there was a light bulb out he
would unscrew the light bulb out and he
would
to the district manager okay and you do
that across a company consistently for
three four or five years people pay
attention
1,000% yeah and it's a big thing so
curiosity is one thing the other thing
is phone call in here yeah the other
thing is operational fun god excellence
we were sticklers for that now you're
always trying to figure out if you're
doing the right thing for your customers
yes but we really worked hard at that
you guys built a crazy company we did
you really did a lot of people do who
were who were your core competitors when
you guys kind of like well in your prime
of your career when you kind of took on
well in Sprint t-mobile were there and
you know arrive and ring back down while
your party here's some who's competitor
when you first started that is no longer
out there now oh we got somebody it's
gary vaynerchuk you're on with Ivan
please say hello hey Gary Vee awesome
you guys are amazing I love your show
thank you
basically I was I actually am a current
of member of Verizon Wireless and the
whole thing with 5g and our stock and
telecommunications I mean what's our
future gonna look like or you know for
small businesses as I couldn't make
everything grow but small business or 5g
it's gonna bring your in your opinion
Ivan as somebody who's just very like
kind of headline reading at this point
and started digging in but I've dug in
because there are some clear things that
are interested in with 5g maybe based on
that question for everybody who's
listening and I don't know how much or
how little you've gone deep into 5g but
if you have gone a little bit deeper
which I'm gonna make assumptions but not
necessarily based on where you are at
this point what's what are some of the
head like what are some of the real
bullet points that I think that you
think people are either missing or the
most exciting things to you about this
technology right so let me make sure I
qualify by saying that I no longer speak
for the company I know that but I love
the understand and and thank you for
your call and for Verizon Wireless you
guys are doing great so keep it up so
thank you very much so 5g so what's
different about five G yes so first it's
a couple of things so first of all the
number of the device Rob thanks for
callin brother
the number of devices you connect in a
one square mile is an order of magnitude
higher than this today so you could
create services in which you have
millions of the devices in a very small
geographic area they use less power so
you can do the same thing with far less
power the latency the speed of switching
calls much lower that seems to be a
really accessible easy things seems to
be and then the unique plan and then the
amount of data that you can transmit is
an order of magnitude like ten tenfold
and the other thing is the cost to
transmit the data is much lower so when
you look at I think the name itself
confuses the end consumer because it's
one tick up yet the magnitude is so
extraordinary yeah and that's the same
thing happened when we went doesn't orgy
that's right but with three to four G
and correct me if I'm wrong it seems
especially on latency which I think
affects a lot of things it seems like
the jump here is kind of like a
signature jump I just think a lot of
people assume my stuff's gonna be faster
and there's just so much more to it so
let's use example please you've heard
these examples before so we'll take the
easy one self-driving cars okay so you
know whether you believe you like it or
not the fact is over time when you can
reduce the latency and increase the
topography and the maps you eliminate a
lot of problems and you could actually
run cities so Verizon today is
introducing smart cities and Sacramento
and Portland and traffic lights they can
do that's one thing so something more
exotic think of healthcare with
broadband you could do an operation with
a patient sitting in Auburn University
and the doctor could be in San Francisco
because the lack of the latency right
because of the speed of the connections
in real-time the clarity in real-time
and just think of what you can do for
example health services to rural America
or health services and to poor area so
let's people who can't travel you know
that kind of thing just think what you
can kind of services you can offer to
the elderly a latchkey so that's not our
thing in the phone company I mean we do
the infrastructure that's right you're
the pipes within
and I always get uncomfortable that we
have to explain what the applications
are or what the market needs to do the
market will catch up to it it'll do it
market are created but the
infrastructure network and pipes in
essence allow for so many more
innovations well just think like what
you're reading now which again you could
like it or not but all of a sudden the
gambling industry has figured this out
and just thinking what they're gonna do
with you can literally bet on this pitch
right because the speed in which it's
happening now is not vulnerable to the
connection and you could be sitting in
Miami betting on a game in Chicago
that's right okay we literally this
pitch right because I mean it really
does matter yes now that may not be the
perfect use of 5g but there may be other
things somebody getting escapism because
they love betting on every pitch of
baseball to back to you you said
something very important which is the
big things you were doing at Verizon
well for the three-person startup in
Cincinnati that you're helping their
problems are the biggest problems to
them in the world to the person who
literally got shot and is in a hospital
and can be helped by somebody who
understands this situation better than
anybody there and can electronically do
it from somewhere away guess what
staying alive is the biggest thing in
the world but the person sitting in
their living room who's not happy with
their life and needs escapism and needs
to gamble on a baseball game to be able
to get through their day that's their
most important thing at their at their
life and I think that's just humans yeah
I'll use my please my favorite whipping
toy here so you think about it I grew up
in an area where you had a go to a
sports event you know go to the stadium
you participate in sports right now it's
virtual you go watch any soccer game any
game anytime you want so the one
industry that's never changed its model
is education yeah joins me crazy it
after we guides me crazy that we could
be teaching people so much quicker if we
apply to all this technology in a way
what about a lack that we continue to
teach people to memorize information
when information is that your
finger let's just how about the
curriculum that fills the format you
know it's absurd you know what we're
doing with that well your audience
understands this so well but but it
takes there's hope there's really a lot
of well there's there's also it's also
on us this goes back to accountability
if Pete if parents continue to think a
diploma from a college is the KPI and is
going to set their kids up for happiness
and success we will continue to be
vulnerable I think what you know it's
funny I think that television
commercials are grossly overpriced media
and I've been advocating that as an
adman of the new version for the last
decade I just thought that biggest
brands in the world would become more
educated over time and know how to spend
their money more wisely I did not
anticipate OTT networks like Hulu and
Amazon Prime and Netflix to completely
eliminate over time people even
consuming the content of the big three
networks let alone the commercials I
feel like that's what's gonna happen
with education this is not gonna be the
education system figuring itself out
because there's too many inherent
interests needs and putting history on a
pedestal this is something coming from
the outside disrupting it at a level
that it has no choice yeah well there's
enough competition in education yeah and
the cab industry wasn't gonna make it
better for us so that we could get a
phone to pick me up in two seconds cuz
time is valuable to me
it took an outside force and then
everybody kicks in you know for many
years one of the trouble one of the
challenges we had his kids coming out of
either high school or college didn't
have the minimum requirements to do the
jobs that we had I get it so we would
have to spend from an engineering
standpoint not those jobs but you know
customer facing jobs
I say technicians jobs so we had a we
spent a lot of money training people
that yeah to do things that they should
have learned in school I get it right
listen we could have 17 episodes of our
points of view on school clearly no I'm
positive about it because I think this
will there is a will in this country and
as long as we don't destroy the culture
of people wanting to succeed and live
the American dream and work this will
get somebody back to not getting
political we won't destroy that's the
DNA of this place like there's this subs
and flows but the DNA of this plate now
look every Empire Falls for a reason too
much success well there's a lot of
competition in the world so I think of
anything
we'll have to respond to that yeah the
kid growing up in China as an only child
in a lower-class family is way more
hungry than you and that's gonna play
out well it's sure well I appreciate you
being on the show thank you for having
us thank you